well leaders will soon meet in Paris to
try to make a climate deal their aim is
to curb greenhouse gas emissions to stop
the world heating up by more than two
degrees compared to before the
Industrial Revolution but what does a
world that two degrees warmer look like
and if the deal fails and global warming
carries on unchecked then what will the
world look like by the end of the
century computer models can help us
project the effects of global warming
for example increasing temperatures will
change the extreme weather that the
world experiences let's think about the
hottest and rainiest days you could
expect to happen before the Industrial
Revolution that's these these days are
so extremely hot or wet they happened
only once every three years on average
but they're the kind of events that can
cause wildfires or flooding so what
happens if the world heats up by two
degrees the limit we're trying to stay
under a hotter atmosphere holds more
water vapor so a rule would expect these
heavy rainfall days to happen about
fifty percent more often the picture for
hot days is even more dramatic a two
degree hotter world would have about 25
times more of these days compared before
the Industrial Revolution of course it's
not just extreme weather that we have to
worry about sea levels are also on the
rise I cheap smelting and the heat
expanding the ocean could mean sea
levels rise by about 60 centimeters by
2100 compared to the eighteen hundreds
bad news for countries like the Marshall
Islands so these are some of the impacts
of a two degree world the limit world
leaders are aiming for but what if we
don't do anything to curb our missions
well then we're heading for a world
that's more like four degrees hotter
than pre-industrial times in this world
the Seas could rise by a total of a meat
or more compared to before the
Industrial Revolution
back cause serious flooding for
low-lying cities like Miami and Bangkok
and what about the weather it's hard to
be sure what a 4-degree world would look
like but we can be sure they would have
even bigger extreme impacts the downpour
days have more than doubled and we're
looking at around a hundred times the
number of extremely hot days that's
going to make areas like the Middle East
uninhabitable which of these two worlds
are we heading for based on the science
and what countries have said they'll do
so far we're adding somewhere in between
around three degrees in fact
temperatures have already risen by about
naught point eight degrees since the
Industrial Revolution staying under two
degrees could mean having to suck huge
amounts of co2 out of the atmosphere
something we don't yet have the
technology for so what world leaders
decide in Paris will have a huge impact
on what world we're living in at the end
of this century and if we're going to
stay under two degrees the Paris meeting
is only the start
you